remember the name Haley Bennett
she is Hollywood's new it girl her new
movie the girl on the train opens today
so before you ask there's everything you
need to know about Haley this is
exciting because I know that my parents
watch Entertainment Tonight and I know
that can I just say hi hi my family I
love you
you can cut Haley some slack for giving
a big shout-out to her family back in
Ohio after ten years of struggling to
make it this 28 year old has arrived and
in a big way it's a dream come true
really I can't believe it here will you
pinch me please thank you she's in
count'em five big movies including the
Magnificent Seven with Denzel and Chris
Pratt O'Shea we work for her but it's
Halley's twisted performance in the girl
on the train that's catching a lot of
buzz right now I actually missed being
the other one and many in Hollywood are
comparing her to the reigning box-office
queen Haley I've got to ask how many
times a day do you get Jennifer Lawrence
because you guys really do resemble each
other
I really admire her and I think that
she's had an incredible career and I
guess we both have blonde hair at first
glance you think Jayla did a cameo in
the girl on the train same running shots
same sort of sultry stare and they've
also shared the same co-star Edgar
Ramirez plays Hailey's therapist
he was Jennifer's ex-husband enjoy
that's funny now Haley has also said
that if this acne thing doesn't work out
she would like to be a professional chef
she's also an avid hunter and knows how
to dress a deer
you